how early is it for people to pick
winners meaning
you know the saying wow you know the
never in the history the NBA has a team
come back from being three up and it's
all kindly Celtics tomorrow
if the Celtics win tomorrow in Miami
it's games you're gonna go back to
Celtics
winning games six it's over so here's
the top the point I'm making to you is
is is is the scientist Jimmy Butler or
is the scientist Tatum is this going to
be a situation where Miami is up three
nothing Celtics come back Trump is up
three nothing right now with the big ass
lead what is the likelihood that the
santis without a blunder from the other
side meaning if Trump gets indicted if
Trump they're going to take them down
and he can't compete which any of those
things can happen as well but say that
doesn't happen what is the likelihood of
DeSantis beating Trump in the primary
give me a percentage
it all depends oh my God
you want a story okay
at this point I've been hearing so many
facts I like a couple stories you know
Trump is actually gonna get on the
debate stage he will of course you think
he will that's the biggest X Factor you
don't think that guy wants to talk guys
that's like Saint John Jones doesn't
want to fight yeah well he was doing
cocaine he couldn't fight for a little
while John he loves to fight you know
you I hear you but it's not like I just
came up with the story out of [__]
nowhere yeah there's been chatter about
Trump not being on the debate stage so
the point is let's assume he's going to
be on the debate stage yeah
um who's gonna be on the debate stage
you got DeSantis you got Pence yeah you
might have Mike Pompeo yeah well you
have sununu you got Nikki Haley you got
Scotty Swami so let's see how he takes
that barrage of attack versus dishing it
out so I think it's gonna be made for
TV Prime Time way better than it was in
16 and 20. okay because now there's
people his VP is talking [__] to him
what's the problem so what the
percentage is they making a comebacks
winning winning the primary yeah 30
percent
he's not Donald Trump is on in Revenge
mode and he just says hold on let me
finish nothing sorry he's in Revenge
mode just from the Durham report by
itself bro Obama Biden Hillary the FBI
everybody colluded to get his ass out
and for all those years he is furious he
wants revenge and he deserves it bro he
deserves it that's what I'm that's it I
think he has a 30 chance unless he does
some outlandish [__] Trump is looking
for fire Rob said this yesterday it's
Don versus Ron 2024. Donald Trump is
gonna he's gonna win bro hear me out
whoever those side people are Rama Swan
you all them Adam it's like who's gonna
team up on who the most you know what I
mean are they going to all go after
Trump more or does Santa smart things
going to be Trump or do Trump Trump's a
legend and I think he's gonna win he's
out for blood period uh I'm kind of a
student of political history and I went
back and I looked and I saw there was a
time when Mike Huckabee for almost two
months was it's a done deal Mike
Huckabee is going to be the nominee it's
a done deal Scott Walker Wisconsin
remember that uh yeah not as long as
Huckabee but yeah you're correct there's
then there's moments where wow Scott
Walker this can be the guy this is done
this is a done deal it's gonna happen or
Jeb Bush never
um and then I'll show you a time where
there was three weeks where Condoleezza
Rice LED all uh candidates so they're in
the traditional elections there tends to
be time where
these things pop up like this and for
Huckabee for Walker for Conde and you
think wow there's our candidate it's
it's over this time and I love saying
this because this is what Silicon Valley
says about the economy all the time and
about new companies right Pat this time
it's different but I do believe this
time it's different I'm I'm at DeSantis
has a 33 chance of getting the
nomination that's where I'm at good good
number Tom and the reason I think that
is it's not impossible but there are so
many things we've already talked about
today I won't listen to them that he
really needs to learn and being a astute
political intellect about the things
that America needs on policy he's got
that covered but that's not what the
people that are out there hurting from
inflation hurting from things they want
and Trump is that guy and Trump has got
the evidence behind him he's like listen
I'm not this bombastic guy look at what
I did and look at what I did with China
was I right I mean the um the thing that
Trump can run on a simple campaign
slogan a dream for America but also was
I right
you could say I said I had nothing to do
with Russia was I right I said that
China was dangerous I should push them
economically was I right I said that the
southern border needed a lot of help and
I didn't get the full wall built because
they blocked me was I right and so
that's pretty powerful now what he can't
walk away from is this very
very you know the offensive side where
you have key parts of the of the voting
blocks that um that like like women
educated women are like ah gosh they
just they just can't get around that but
I think right now it's 33 for uh
DeSantis intellect aside I don't think
he can become the politician he needs to
be to win the mob well you know I'm a
Vegas guy I always I say I don't trust
Pew I don't trust Quinnipiac and all
this stuff so I just quickly
I say because they got skin in the game
and take a guess who is the current
favorite from Vegas take a guess
favorite of all everyone everyone for be
president okay you're going what do you
think I think Vegas is probably gonna
Biden but a little bit more okay then
who's number two Trump trump okay and
then who's number three Ron okay by the
way you said 33 you said 30. 30 said 33
uh roll the dice right here buddy uh Joe
Biden is the favorite uh six to four
odds so what is that 66 give or take
yeah uh Donald Trump twelve to five odds
which is about 40 percent 12 divided by
five Rhonda Sanchez 25 that's where it
is and then it falls off a cliff then
you got RFK Kamala Michelle Gavin Nikki
so it's a three-legged race three horse
race Joe Biden at the top right now
that'll obviously change once there's a
clear Republican nominee right uh Trump
and DeSantis 25 that's where Vegas puts
it right now you've got Tucker and Pence
tied at 50-1 Tim Scott Hillary Clinton's
even on there that's actually not a bad
Buy
that's actually not a bad buy Believe it
or what Hillary Clinton at age one no I
you know why that's not a bad buy
because she never underestimate a
ambitious lazy person who is willing to
do anything and everything it takes to
get to the top she is the ultimate lazy
ambitious person that wants to be a
president and very deceptive very strong
uh she can move a lot of different
things for that to happen go a little
bit higher look at Michelle Obama ahead
of Newsome but ahead of Nick yaley yeah
yeah because there's an open field on
the left so much on the right one
observation Pat look at how many
Republicans from vivec to all these
people that that the the right has the
left has no who is his left half Robert
Kennedy okay I get it but then comma
they have nobody not about candidates
but that's what I'm saying is I'm saying
look at the pool look at that people the
right has the left is just barely
hanging bro gang
that's a for sure miss but even if you
think about it okay they have Biden who
else do they really have besides Kenny
they don't like the Republicans six to
four in the face of unsorted confusion
as soon as it's less confused those
that's the worst bet to make
to say Biden's good like that Joe
manchin 101. let me let me explain some
dude Joel if okay if the people that
voted for Biden because they just wanted
to get Trump out if you still vote for
Biden with the [__] that's been
happening you are an idiot okay and the
only way he's gonna win is if God forbid
this new pandemic that the who just said
is coming out that all these people are
warning us about fauci everybody and you
have to stay home and vote there is no
way in in if you if he wins something is
off something is wrong don't even how
can you clearly vote for somebody after
what the hell we've been seeing for
these three years you lived in
California for 10 years I think you know
what they've no no no what are you
talking about what I'm saying is it was
Trump and coven okay finally the the
orange bad crazy man he's gone now you
we got Joe Biden
abysmal presidency so far what I'm
saying is the fact that he's number one
if he wins the the entire presidency
something is wrong Joe Biden is the goat
upside down though Joe Biden is the gold
from the other way yeah yeah if he's
just gonna they're gonna trust me bro
they're gonna keep him in the White
House how do you
explain to me how he can win who how can
you vote for Joe Biden right now in your
right mind it's tell me that if somebody
says infrastructure I'm gonna walk out
of that okay I'm not I'm not trying to
sell you this but I I guarantee you
without a doubt 49 to 50 percent of the
country will vote for him that's bananas
what do you mean they already did it no
but yeah because he'll do it again
because that's insane I don't want you
to I don't want your brains to end up
all over them I don't want it to blow
it's going to happen it's just expect it
it's going to be a close election then
50 of people are stupid and you're
stupid so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
thank you
[Music]